let's talk a little bit about ionic
solids which you can imagine are solids
formed by ions so let's think a little
bit about these ions
so for example we could look at group
one elements here especially things like
lithium or sodium or potassium and in
many other videos we have talked about
these elements wanting
maybe not so much to keep their
outermost electron because they only
have one electron in their outermost
shell and it'd be pretty easy for them
to lose that electron to get to a noble
gas configuration to have a full outer
shell so these characters like to lose
one electron the group two elements like
to lose two electrons well if you go on
the other side of the periodic table if
you look at the halogens right over here
they are one electron away from having a
noble gas electron configuration from
having a full outer shell so they really
like to grab electrons and if you look
at elements like oxygen and sulfur they
really like to grab two electrons if
they can so what do you think happens if
you have some metals on the left end
here mixed with some non-metals on the
right end here well you might imagine
there would be a reaction
so for example if you mixed sodium with
chlorine the sodiums might lose an
electron to the chlorines in which case
you're going to have sodium
cations positively charged ions and if
the chlorines are now taking those
electrons they then become chloride
anions
and now if you have a bunch of positive
ions hanging about hanging around a
bunch of negative ions what do you think
is going to happen they're going to get
attracted to each other and they're
going to get attracted to each other and
form a lattice structure like this i
like to use sodium chloride as an
example because this is probably the one
that we see most in our life this is
table salt if you were to lick it it
tastes salty
but there's many other ionic solids many
of them would actually be categorized as
salts generally you could have a
potassium chloride you could have a
sodium
fluoride you could have for example a
magnesium oxide what's going on there
well in that situation the magnesium
each magnesium might lose two electrons
so they become a ion with a positive two
charge and each of the oxygens would
gain two electrons so then they are
anions with a negative two charge and
then these characters once again are
going to be attracted to each other and
form an ionic solid in a regular lattice
structure like this
so let's think a little bit about their
properties
so first of all let's think about the
melting points
so these solids the electrostatic
attraction between these ions is strong
and so they tend to have high melting
points and what if we were to compare
melting points between ionic solids so
for example if you wanted to compare the
melting point of sodium
chloride
to the melting point of magnesium
oxide which one do you think has a
higher melting point pause this video
and think about it
well as you can imagine the
electrostatic attraction it's going to
be dependent on two things the magnitude
of the charge and the radius of the
atoms that are forming this lattice
structure and the magnitude of the
charge here is clear here you have a
plus two charge being attracted to a
negative two charge so this has a
stronger electrostatic attraction and so
you're going to have a higher melting
point
right over here the melting point of
magnesium oxide
2825 degrees celsius while the melting
point of table salt or sodium chloride
is
801 degrees celsius
you could also try to compare sodium
chloride to something like
sodium
fluoride
which one do you think is going to have
a higher melting point sodium chloride
or sodium fluoride
well fluorines are smaller than
chlorines and if each of them gain an
electron then the fluoride anion is
still going to be a reasonable bit
smaller than the chloride anion when you
have smaller constituent ions the
electrostatic attraction is actually
stronger remember we've seen in
coulomb's law that the closer two
charges are to each other the stronger
the attractive or the repulsive force
and if they're opposite charges it's
going to be an attractive force so
sodium fluoride is actually going to
have a higher melting point than sodium
chloride by a little bit it actually
turns out that the melting point of
sodium fluoride is
996 degrees celsius and if you're
comparing these three the highest
melting point is magnesium oxide
followed by sodium fluoride followed by
sodium chloride so charge is what's
really dominating over here now the next
question you might be wondering is all
right i can imagine these solids are
really hard but what would happen if i
were to try to break it would it bend
like a lot of the metals we know and
we'll study that in other videos or
would something else happen
and to understand that let me draw a
two-dimensional representation of this
so let me draw the chlorine or i should
say the chloride anions
and this is just a two-dimensional
version
of that lattice obviously not drawing it
to scale and then let me draw
the sodiums
sodium cations
as you can see the positives are
attracted to the negative that's why
they're next to each other the negatives
aren't next to each other because they
repel each other the positives aren't
next to each other but what would happen
if i were to try to if i were to press
down really hard on this side and if i
were to press
really hard up on these on this side
so what would happen if i press hard
enough that this side
begins to budge so it begins to budge
would it just bend
or what do you think's gonna happen when
i get right about there
well when i get right about there
all of a sudden i've bro not only have i
broken the lattice but the negatives are
next to the negatives and the positives
are next to the positives and so it's
not just going to bend and be malleable
like a lot of the metals we've seen it's
just going to break so this is going to
be even though it's going to be hard it
is going to be brittle now the last
question we'll address in this video is
how good do you think ionic solids
conduct electricity pause this video and
think about that
well in order to conduct electricity
either electrons or charge generally has
to be able to move about and when it's
just in its solid form like this
the even though you do have these ions
they're not going to move about so ionic
solids in their solid form they aren't
good at conducting electricity they can
be good at conducting electricity if you
were to dissolve it in a solution for
example if you were to dissolve this
salt in water now the ions can move
around and then they're good at
conducting electricity or if you were to
heat the sodium chloride up beyond 801
degrees celsius and it turns into a
liquid then once again the ions can move
around and you can actually conduct
electricity take everything i say with a
grain of salt i'm sorry i know i
couldn't help it but hopefully you know
a little bit more about ionic solids now